hey guys how's it going so i'm really
excited about this unboxing you guys
might have seen the video that i posted
previously while me and my sister went
out in some crazy los angeles traffic to
hunt down one of the very few game stops
that had some of the new galaxy ds's i
called a bunch of stores and they're
like no we don't have it yet i was like
but why not so here it is it's beautiful
it's shining it's shimmering it's
spacely purple and space and sort of the
galaxy theme is one of my favorite
things in the entire world so when i saw
that this thing was released i was so
happy let's open this bad boy up
oh my goodness it just never gets old to
me are you ready come and get it
ready for the reveal
[Music]
i haven't even flipped it around yet
but you guys are seeing it before me
[Music]
wow
so when you look at it face on it's it's
definitely has a ton of reflective
qualities to it it's got a nice little
silver finish here with the stars in the
galaxy and the milky way
this back is a nice little purple as
well so one of the downsides of the new
nintendo 3ds is the new the new nintendo
3ds it's it's confusing i feel like they
probably could have thought of a
different name but the new nintendo 3ds
that just came out i think was like
maybe two years ago at this point i have
lost track you need a little screwdriver
to open it up and put in the sd cards i
did a video on this i think on my gaming
channel about how to update it and
change it it's pretty simple but i
always lose screwdrivers they no longer
come with a charging cable so if you do
happen to get one and you don't already
have one make sure you buy one because
they don't come with it any longer my
recommendation is get one of the usb
chargers i'll put a link in the
description they have ones that will
charge various models of your ds's so if
you get one you can basically charge
them all i've got two different options
in the description so you guys can check
those out i prefer the usb chargers
because i can plug it into my ds and
then plug it into my laptop to charge or
plug it into an external charging
battery like some of the mophies that i
use to charge my phone so basically i'll
be able to have power wherever i am as
long as i can find a usb port that's
usually pretty easy to find so
i mean i haven't turned it on yet
i'm gonna have to do the whole transfer
and the setup and then i'm sure you guys
will see this in some future vlogs so
stay tuned for that my question to you
guys is what games are you guys playing
on ds i'm really looking forward to
pokemon sun and moon it will be the
first pokemon game that i've ever played
outside of pokemon go and i know that
sounds super crazy but for some reason i
have always avoided pokemon games it
just wasn't something that i thought
that i would be into and at this point
in my life i'm extremely glad that i
avoided them because i am quite sure
that my entire childhood would have been
completely different i would have been
obsessed i would have actually had to
catch them all and my mom probably would
have
put me on the street because she's like
girl
we can't catch them all thank you guys
so much for watching i look forward to
booting this bad boy up let me know what
you guys think let me know what ds you
guys have or what games you plan on
playing here in the near future
peace out we are on a secret
mission a secret road trip if you will
to
beverly hills